But John,
in 1997,
the NHS budget was 33 point 5 billion in
2010.
It was 115 billion.
What's that?
Is that not a triplet?
You're doing cash to carry.
Do it in real terms.
You're not going to be used in real
terms.
I've talked about the NHS budget.
Are you talking about cash?
Are you talking?
You don't talk in real terms,
in real terms,
budgets.
See,
this is the whole problem with arguing
with this exact problem.
My family stays on you.
This is the whole problem which the book
cuts through every time one says
something,
which is based on the fact the
government publishes the statistics say
the government spending on nhs,
it seems simple,
is 33 point 5 billion and in 2010 is
over 110 billion.
There is no dispute about that and yet
the moment labor people of their rights
get a fat,
they try and twist and turn it so that,
for example,
now when Professor Brown eloquently
explained the decline of math education
in Britain,
matthew immediately jumped to say,
well,
it's because the housing problem.
This is the problem.